this this is it the spot where comics go
after the show - just shoot the
tonight I'm here to work
that's right new material I love the
usual thanks doll Sam oh hey Mark
it's Tim right I'm good you know just
doing shows the norm
ah yes isn't it the best all I need is a
microphone in front of me and a brick
wall behind me and that Rory just takes
over no
right very right yeah same just a
bare-bones media here oh thank you
Reggie it's actually Luke oh my god you
two are literally obsessed with names
dope when the crowd is in my hand
Khomeini's are like rock stars hello we
like the new philosophers wait we're
like those I'm actually trainer right
right now so could you not how do you
mean trying to be rude just okay now
back to writing new material it's gotta
be honest
no I need to be now I need to tackle the
political climate
yes this is it hard-hitting honest and
political I don't know maybe it's too
hard and not Bill Hicks after all
therefore this my new bit that a bit
yeah that's a bit I like that cause it's
like is Macri dead I don't know I know
right back yeah I'm incredible kills for
the bar